foreign
buck
hi this is Buck Helen of Montana curious
about paper clutter and how the best way
to work with that doesn't care about it
when I need order
it's something that just eats at me
every day and I think I have a fairly
good handle on it but just curious what
triggers or what things or what ways I
can do to help subside some of that
anxiety thanks so much
Buck it sounds like you need to
declutter the other person in your life
and that will bring great order right in
fact if we have no relationships in our
life at all then my life will be perfect
and complex I mean this is the story I
tell myself sometimes because I relate
to Buck I need my space to be a
particular way I'm obsessive and
compulsive and paper clutter also drives
me crazy and I'll give you some rules
that we've set up that I think will help
one is the no piles Rule and if you're
doing this with someone else in the
house you have to get them on board you
have to show them the why behind it
instead of just the what or the how to
how to's are boring and the people don't
want to see like oh you what you're just
telling me that I have a new rule that I
have to follow that doesn't help anyone
in our house though what we do is we
have something called the no piles rule
we don't let any mail or packages or
bags or any accessories pile up on the
counter flat surfaces become a
repository for excess stuff that I don't
want to deal with right now and so the
no piles rule says at the end of each
day we eliminate any piles that have
accumulated on flat surfaces I do want
to talk specifically about paper clutter
and address this with you because this
question comes up a lot around paper
clutter and I think there are the three
most common types of paper clutter are
photos books and then documents usually
we think about documents we think about
paper clutter we got this mail that we
keep here receipts or this tax
information I have to hold on to and
then we start stuffing things into
drawers or file cabinets pretending
we're organizing it but we're just
hoarding the clutter in a different way
and so I'll address these one at a time
really quickly by the way you can go
back and listen to our paper clutter
episode it's episode 322 if you want to
do a deep dive on a paper clutter we
also did a episode called hidden clutter
because one of the most Insidious forms
of hidden clutter are these documents
and photos and things that that creep
into our lives that are hidden forms of
clutter that's episode 272 for hidden
clutter we'll put links to both of those
in the show notes but real quick if you
want to deal with your photos you can
get a photo scanner like the one we have
I'll put a link to the photo scanner
that I use in actually Ryan and I share
it and so like we'll go back and forth
if I need to scan some photos and that
way we don't each have to have one right
and so you can share this because it's a
couple hundred bucks to have a really
good high quality photo scanner but then
you can scan all the photos you have in
your house and what you'll learn is most
of those folders you're holding on to if
they weren't worth being scanned they
probably weren't worth holding on to in
the first place and that also gives me a
backup as well even if I want to hold on
to the some physical photos what happens
if I have a flood or a fire well now I
can have them backed up on my hard drive
or in the cloud I use dropbox you can
use whatever service you want to use
like Google photos to have some
redundancy there as well I also have a
separate hard drive so if anything were
to happen those photos and then beyond
that if besides your photos any books
that you're holding on to that are kind
of getting in the way especially old I
find a lot of people put on the old
textbooks that they're never going to
reference again but they think they
might just need it one day the truth is
you could probably let go of those
things but there might be some books
where you're like I reference them
occasionally so I don't want to get rid
of them well there's a service
onedollarscan.com that will scan your
books for you and they will incinerate
the old book so you don't have to deal
with it anymore
in onedollarscan.com they are not a
sponsor of ours at all I have used them
for a couple things in the past and then
they will send you the digital file so
guess what the books are now searchable
you can type in the keyword and you can
find the passage in the book that you
were looking for in the first place it
makes it so much easier and it gets rid
of that clutter if you don't want to
scan your own photos by the way scan
myphotos.com is a really great website
again not a sponsor we're not affiliated
with them in any way but
scanmyphotos.com if you just have a box
of photos you want to send to them
they'll take care of it for you they
will scan your photos and get rid of
those photos send them to you on a disk
or a digital file so you have access to
those things I'm also going to put a
link in the show notes to the 10 best
scanning services for 2023. it's a
little article you have there but what
do we do about our document clutter
because that is a whole other thing the
truth is I don't hold on to many
documents as soon as I scan them I get
rid of them there are a few documents I
have to have but even those I have
digital copies and I generally don't
need to have a physical copy we always
hear you have to hold on to your taxes
for seven years so I talked to my
accountant talk to your accountant
before you do this but
um I talked to my account and say as
long as you have the digital version of
your taxes you're totally fine you don't
have to have a paper copy of everything
I do have a paper copy of a few things I
have one file that has like my social
security card and it has my birth
certificate and a few other things that
I do need the physical copy of but
everything else is digitized now there
are a couple ways you can do that if you
have an iPhone or a smartphone generally
you can just use the camera on there as
a scanner now Apple notes is a great
scanning program turns your photos into
a PDF which is really helpful for any
paper clutter that you have and you deal
with it right away so you're not waiting
till the end of the year several years
later you got stacks of papers you have
to deal with one more link I'm going to
put into the show notes and I'll be
interested in tkc if you have any
questions about this this is an article
from
indormood.com and it's called had enough
of paper clutter this is the best system
it's like 12 pages long so I'm not going
to read the whole thing but I really
like their system if you're looking for
a system to remove document clutter in
your life
here's what they use every tool you'll
need to conquer paper clutter here's a
list of supplies you'll need for this
system number one inbox I use a simple
basket from Ikea that can sit on a shelf
now obviously you can get a box inbox
from anywhere right Amazon Target you
can make one yourself you can go to Etsy
get a local maker who makes a beautiful
basket for you just make sure you check
first to see which store your particular
political group is protesting right now
so that you don't buy the wrong product
and be happy by mistake
so having some sort of box for your
papers and I think this helps with the
no piles rule as well having a place to
put that stack of papers so that you
have one destination you'll have a pile
of papers here a pile of papers here a
few on my desk nope you've got one inbox
for your papers they sit there until you
have time to process them I would do
that daily personally but maybe call it
once a week for you I'm gonna process
these once a week so you're not dealing
with it a month month from now a quarter
from now a year from now a huge stack of
papers that's when it becomes
overwhelming but if you have a small
stack from one day or even one week
guess what it's not a big deal number
two a fast duplex document scanner we'll
put a link to the document scanner that
I use personally it's document and photo
so you can kill two birds with one stone
or massage two birds with one stone how
about that and so uh use some sort of
scanner for your documents you can feed
them right in or if you don't have that
many documents you can just use your
phone for that as well having a computer
is number three on here obviously so
this person says I use my laptop for
everything working on professional
contracts following recipes for the
kitchen blogging Etc of course using my
computer for the scan documents is one
thing that I do number four this is
often overlooked up having a paper
shredder I don't have one at home we
have one here at the studio so I'll
often just bring a stack of papers I
want to shred head in my bag that way I
don't have to own two of them we already
have one I have access to one or quite
often if you have a local document
Center like a FedEx Kinkos or just a
local business center they usually have
shredding or incinerating services and
they charge you like a penny per page or
a penny per 10 pages or whatever it
might be so you don't have to buy a
paper shredder we'll put a link to a
paper shutter that we use downstairs it
is a high grade one we can shred 20 30
pages at once which is awesome but you
don't need that to be able to get rid of
those sensitive documents number five
online cloud backup I use dropbox this
person says I use iDrive you know
whatever service works well for you we
don't recommend one in particular a
small file box is number six
um and so that's if you are actually
going to file some stuff away there are
some things you may want to keep I have
a file cabinet at home works really well
for me but having a small file box can
work also I have excess room in that
file cabin that feels good every time I
open it there's like one little folder
in there and I have a few little
accessories I keep my pins and and a few
other things in there as well and they
use a few other things here on art
portfolio some photo boxes to-do lists
with Google keep calendar notebook
staple remover those are the things they
use to organize their document clutter
we'll put a link to this article in the
show notes any questions or anything to
add TK man that's a very thorough and
helpful list I learned a few new tricks
from that I'll address one
um related area here because it sounds
like there's not just a digital clutter
or a paper clutter issue but also a
communication clutter because if there
were no other people involved it sounds
like Buck would Implement a system and
would be happy with it but it sounds
like it's the addition of other people
right that kind of throws them off and
so
um one thing I just say to add on is
that persuasion is is not just a matter
of rhetoric but it's also a matter of
conviction how you feel when you are
articulating what your needs are and
what the boundaries are is going to have
as much of an impact on how that other
person receives you as the words you use
it's kind of like when a little baby is
is crawling in trips or something like
that and then the baby looks at you for
that decisive Split Second and if you go
the baby goes or if you go oh you're
okay the baby starts crying like there
are these moments where it's our
reaction that affects how other people
feel about it and so if you're real
defensive about what you need it's going
to feel like we're in a fight even if
you're articulating yourself perfectly
right and so get clear with yourself
about why this matters to you and how
you you want to fill at home and then
you can have a conversation before you
say a word about boundaries that goes
something like hey when I come home from
A Hard Day's Work
there's nothing that I love more than my
home feeling like a safe haven a place
of peace and a big part of that for me
is just an orderly household and I'm not
asking anyone to be just like me to need
what I need or to think that anything
that they do is wrong but I love to make
some suggestions here for some things
that would really work well for me and
make me a lot healthier and I would love
to get your feedback and see if we can
find a way to make it work for everybody
because even though sometimes
you can play the power card and be like
this is how it's going to be and you can
get away with it be careful because you
change the dynamic of the relationship
once you do that there's nothing sweeter
than getting people to cooperate with
you by enlisting them and enrolling them
voluntarily getting them on board with
your vision rather than trying to rule
by Fiat and manipulation because you
might get what you want but what you
have to sacrifice energetically at your
home just reproduces the problem in
another area so those would be my tips
on how to make it make the needs known
here yeah and I think also what you're
exposing here if it gets in the way it's
clutter and so the other person in the
house may not see it as clutter because
it's not getting in the way for them but
you probably have the same problem that
I have I want my house to look like no
one lives in it
and who you live with who you're living
with they don't care about yeah that
they don't care about Aesthetics the
same way you do they don't care about
paper clutter the same way you do the
document clutter the same same way you
do they're not wrong for that you have
different preferences you're also not
wrong for it but there isn't a real
problem here the problem is the way that
we perceive it and then that problem is
Amplified by how we communicate as TK
just Illustrated yeah did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcasts available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free